welcome to this video haunt for 13 okay
this guy is yet to score any any kind of
point I've got four wins against them
but it's pretty decently rated so must
have been a kind of a good run that I
had don't remember any of those games
really all right this line add this yeah
yeah don't remember I had one of I had a
game with that against him that's true
okay I'm just going to develop here
normally with Bishop d3 c5 okay I'm
going to take we don't want an IQ p
position with the bishop on f1 is kind
of awkward most of the time and
interesting going to take with the Queen
I don't think so Quincy two wins the
tempo on the edge porn okay so it is sad
yeah that's the structure that I
generally do like I think white is quite
quite comfortable here not surprising
she gives up the center of attention
down do I go efore or 95
should geforce also i move i have to be
a bit we're off so maybe I'm preventing
that yeah that is interesting here the
sea for me I was a bit surprised and
didn't think it's very good at first but
why not you can do that he definitely
can do that okay so each for otherwise I
don't really see a big point in my
position Bishop is six it probably has
to do it looks very normal at least
maybe intending to capture and play
Bishop t5 well definitely yeah that's
definitely true how do i play whom he
five maybe then Queen d7 might be good
for Bishop f5 yeah I don't like the idea
of him taking and playing on it's
playing Bishop to g5 I absolutely don't
like that
interesting I was only expect a man to
take really but okay not before is
interesting absolutely yes here I
thought that no I don't have any tactic
down if I'm going to work probably
really have to move the night question
is where knight Knight g4 might be an
interesting way to go night coming to e3
possibly and also night h6 maybe
sometimes
if I take down d5 fe5 queen age five
plants that's not going to work really
isn't some Bishop chicks
sure yet weird weird pollution yeah f5
f5 is in the in the mix them
I can check on d5 at least I got the e5
square then
ya kun takes 93 is definitely okay for
me I get d5 d6 everything and so Bishop
g5 looks a better I think d 5f form GD
fire should be okay 24 should be okay I
think and for Queenie for Bishop d3
Bishop f4 sizes definitely definitely
all right okay d 6 here again f4 is a
month I cannot go f3 unfortunately f
should be five maybe
okay we should if I see three was my
idea if he takes the pawn them I'm can I
can play in with this opposite colored
bishops it's not great but well I can go
F for of course they don't have anything
great against that Queen g4s this move
may be okay you can take III of course
and III and f2
Jim I really didn't play that one in any
kind of decent way I came so it's not
threatening to take time morning still
don't have any any move here my night
has has no squares whatsoever
about amazing amazingly bad position
you don't even think that was the
hardest way to punish me but it still
looks quite awful gone down and he had
the bishop at least not anymore but okay
I'm threatening Bishop for at least
might be able to not really really CS
coveted okay um maybe here for seven
18 seconds was a very lucky turn of
events of course
yeah unbelievable he really totally
killed me a check check check check
check check check black4 fits on time
yeah Wow now that was really a bad game
I completely toasted him I wonder what I
did wrong that it's really not not so
clear to me this is still looks fairly
normal let's say but earlier he wasn't
trouble quickly and this this doesn't
look it looks fairly normal why was it
so bad all of a sudden went here b5 yeah
maybe if I it's not really good damn
it's possible I mean it looks like the
natural way to play it a little bit
whether you form but maybe it's not
really right it's possible really went
here and this is probably a totally
wrong idea and night before is a good
move that I not really I was only
thinking okay something like that and I
don't know that that's about equal maybe
but that is just good just strong move
me I mean in trouble already that's it's
really really not about coordinates
position i only lost time there and got
nowhere this is just great for black and
this is probably maybe even worse cheeks
yeah i should have taken they
immediately probably some jam that
that's just it just really bad i should
go we should be five problem
yeah I mean there are maybe ways to
improve I'm but black is completely in
control ya hear hear um this is stronger
though the idea is that if I do this
chad is move check check it's quite a
funny way to checkmate yeah he could
could have taken on b2 and I suspected
that much but yeah I didn't have any of
anything yet in any case went here yeah
this is just a quite unbelievable rookie
7 is not even threatening much second he
can take here and then maybe go there
maybe this is what he wanted to do and
she kind of confused some more water
yeah just if just a gift just a gift
what can you do there was a good game on
this part before you gave away the piece
down but sometimes you just have kind of
always some code on the wrong foot
against people and maybe this is the
case um when he plays me it's got five
losses now in the books okay well thanks
for watching